Just the
beginning,
welcome to now you see what'd be sequels
are impossible to predict,
some become classics and some become the
most hated movies of all time,
so what makes us sql good and why do
sequels have such a hard time not
sucking?
Do the same thing as last time.
Everyone's happy.
Let's compare similar sequels to see
what works and what doesn't.
One of the biggest obstacles with a
great sequel is that you have to do
something new.
Maybe the first movie works great,
but the sequel can't be the same thing
or it'll suck the sequels that we all
love,
mix it up and surprise us.
The first terminator features Arnold
Schwarzenegger as the villain,
and he's such a terrifying villain
because he's not even human.
He's a robotic monster whose only
objective is to kill Sarah Connor.
A lazy,
unsurprising sql would put us in the
same world with the terminator trying to
kill again,
but James Cameron surprises us and in a
spectacular twists,
Arno's is actually sent to protect John
Connor from another more powerful
terminator.
Get down
now.
That's a great sequel and then their
speed.
The first speed is about a cop who tries
to rescue civilians from a bus rigged to
explode.
If any of the civilians tried to get off
or the bus slows down,
it's action packed and suspenseful from
start to finish.
The sequel speed to has the same general
idea,
but the buses now a luxury cruise ship,
the surprise is amazingly lane.
A slow moving cruise ship is way less
thrilling than the fast moving busing.
The first speed,
the surprise isn't a surprise.
It's a letdown.
Sequels also need to build.
They need to add something and what they
add has to be good.
Twenty two jump street has the same
general plot as 21 jump street.
The only real difference between the two
films is that one takes place in high
school and the other in college,
but the second film as a whole gag about
the movie itself,
they constantly make references to have
doing the same thing over and over again
will not lead to the same results.
Always worse the second time around.
They're making fun of the fact that
sequels never work.
They build on 21 jump street by now.
Making fun of themselves.
It's clever,
original,
unique and hilarious.
I can't believe the Korean church back.
Yeah,
I mean,
good thing there was even hit your
abandoned church directly across the
street.
Yes,
it is convenient.
The hangover part two tries to build on
the original instead of taking place in
Las Vegas.
The sequel is in the much more exotic
Thailand,
but that's really the only addition to
the original.
There's nothing new here.
There's no bill.
Leave this happening.
Again,
an inherent problem with feature length
film is that the amount of possible
character development is limited to the
hour and a half length of the movie,
so in a medium like television,
we can see so many complex changes in a
character over the course of several
seasons,
whereas a movie can show maybe one or
two major changes,
but the sql though we have a chance to
see characters we love and the original
grow even more.
I think any sequel that doesn't take
advantage of this opportunity for more
character growth is a disappointment.
Toy Story,
for example,
shows us a whole new character arc for
woody and the sql in the first film,
what he makes the realization that
getting the most attention isn't what's
important.
It doesn't matter how much we have
played with
what matters is that word here for Andy,
he needs us,
and then in the sql what he has another.
That while his time with Andy is
temporary.
He would rather spend his limited time
making andy happy over being displayed
in the museum.
You're right prospector.
I can't stop andy from growing up,
but I wouldn't miss it for the world.
Through the sql,
we get further insight into what he.
At his dedication to Andy,
we learned more about what his goals,
his fears and his obstacles.
The sequel added just as much depth to
the main character as the first film,
which in the end is what turns sequels
into classics.
We can see this added depth to
characters and other great cus like the
Godfather,
part two with Michael Corleone and the
Dark Knight with Bruce Wayne.
When we compare these sequels to
something like cars too,
and the hobbit franchise,
we see another way movie sequels can
suck cars to doesn't show any change to
the characters from the original,
and even with almost eight hours of
screen time for the hobbit series,
we see hardly any character depth in
most of the ensemble cast.
I have to commend to the marvel
cinematic universe for knowing how to
make great sequels.
You can tell from their consistent
continuity writing style crossovers and
brand marketing that Disney isn't making
sequels just for one time cash grabs.
Disney is attempting to make very
longterm profit by creating a lasting
franchise and brand,
and it seems to be working their sql
surprise,
build and add character depth.
Think about the avengers.
We get loads of surprises when our
favorite superheros fight it out.
Build on plots from previous films and
we see tons of character depth by seeing
the conflict of interest between each
superhero.
I'm not saying marvel movies of the
greatest movies of all time,
but what I am saying is that marvel
knows how to make sequels and that's
saying a lot.
Given the callus disappointments we've
seen in sequels,
making a good sql to a great original,
it's definitely a challenge,
but I think a big problem with sequels
is that a lot of the time the studio
doesn't really care if a sequel as well
reviewed with the successful original as
long as sql is okay,
it's almost guaranteed to make a profit
for the studio.
Remember that despite all the hate
towards sequels,
like cars to the hangover part two and
the star wars prequels,
they grossed more than their original
films.
Sequels create an interesting paradox in
the film industry.
To be successful,
a film normally has to show some of the
unique,
like great special effects acting or
plot,
but sql can make a profit only by having
a recognizable name and providing
nothing unique.
So do Hollywood a favor and stop going
to sequels that suck.
God willing.
We'll all meet again in spaceballs to
for more money.
Thanks for watching.